اهلا بكم في هذه النشره الموجزه نفى
المتحدث باسم هيئه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه ان تكون طهران والوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه اتفقا على تركيب كاميرات
مراقبه جديده في المنشاه النوويه واضاف
المسؤول الايراني ان الطرفين لم يتطرقا
للموضوع خلال زياره المدير العام للوكاله
رفع الجروس الى طهران واكد ان زياده
عمليات التفتيش في منشاه فوردو بنسبه 50%
وفقا اعلان جروسي هي ضمن اتفاقيات
الضمانات بعد رفع نسبه التخصيب
وكانت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
اصدرت ميفينا بيانا مشتركا مع هيئه الطاقه
الذريه الايرانيه في ختام زياره مدير عام
الوكاله رفع الجروس الى طهران وقال البيان
ان ايران مستعده لمواصله التعاون مع
الوكاله بشان ثلاثه مواقع قالت الوكاله
انها غير معلنه وعثرت فيها على اثار
اليورانيوم واضاف البيان ان ايران ابدت
استعدادها لتقديم مزيد من المعلومات
بشانها والوصول اليها من اجل معالجه قضايا
الضمانات المتبقيه
وقال مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
رافائيل جروس في فيينا ان البيان المشتركه
مع ايران نتيجه ملموسه وصلبه لمحادثات
الطرفين واضاف ان بعض اجهزه المراقبه في
ايران سيجري تشغيلها قريبا وقال جروسي
الوكاله ستجري تحقيقات باسرع ما يمكن بشان
الاثار النوويه في مواقع غير معلن عنها في
ايران
تقييم الوكاله انه في الوقت الحالي لم
نحصل من ايران على الالتزام الذي نسعى
اليه ولد ايران تقييمه الخاص نحاول تحقيق
تقارب فيما يتعلق بما يسمى القضايا
العالقه بالنسبه لنا كانت العمليه طويله
اكثر مما يجب واعتقد ان تقدما تحقق في
حوار مع الايرانيين اعتقد انه تم الاستماع
الي وسنرى نتائج كما تعرفون في الاشهر
الماضيه كان هناك تقلص لبعض عمليه التفتيش
فيما يتعلق بالكاميرات والمتابعه
الالكترونيه
لا تعمل وقد اتفقنا انها ستعمل من جديد
وسنتفق على طرق تطبيق هذا
وفطر ان نقل مراسل الجزيره عن الرئاسه
الايرانيه قولها ان الرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيسي ابلغ مدير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رفع الجروس بان لدى ايران
اراده قويه وحسن نيه للتعاون مع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه كما قال الرئيس
انطاهران تامل من وكاله الطاقه الذريه
التعامل بمهنيه وعدم التاثر بقوه سياسيه
تسعى لاهداف خاصه
نظم الاتحاد والعام التونسي لشغل تجمعا
عماليا واسعا بالعاصمه تونس في اطار سلسله
تحركات الاحتجاجيه الاسبوعيه واكد الامين
العام للاتحاد نور الدين الطبوبيان
الاتحاد لن يقبل بقمع الحريات ولا بعوده
الاستبداد الى البلاد مهما كانت النتيجه
حسب تعبيره واضاف انه يرفض خطاب ترهيب
الناس وتصفيه الحسابات
انه يستدعيه القضاء او غيره ولكن بالطريقه
انتهى الترهيب وتافه الناس فقال بالليل
على ديار الناس
وبتخوف وترهب من الصغار والشيوخ والنساء
في تلك الطريقه قد ولت وانتهت لان عملنا
ثوره اعمالنا الدوره
من تلك الممارسات
وانتهى
الاستبداد لن نقبل في تونس في هذه
الممارسات
ومع استمرار موجه الاعتقالات قالت جمعيه
القضاه التونسيين ان تصريحات الرئيس قيس
سعيد اتجاه القضاه تشكل خطوره وتداخلا
مباشرا في التحقيقات ودعت الجمعيه في بيان
الرئيسه والسلطه التنفيذيه الى الكف عن
الاجراءات الانتقاميه ضد القضاه لافته الى
وجود ضغوط غير مسبوقه يتعرض لها القضاء
على اثر الاعتقالات الاخيره وكان الرئيس
سعيد قد صرح بانه حان وقت محاسبه من سماهم
المتامرين على امن الدوله واضاف ان على
القضاه المساهمه في معركه التحرير الوطني
على حد تعبيره
قال رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه في ليبيا
عبد الحميد بيبا ان اي قاعده دستوريه يجب
ان تطرح للاستفتاء امام الشعب الليبي
واكدت بيبا في كلمه متلفزه او في ملتقى
خاص باسرى ثوره السابع عشر من فبراير في
مصرات تاكد ان الحل الوحيد للازمه الحاليه
يتمثل في وجود دستور توافقي بين جميع
الاطراف واضاف ان عوده الحكم العسكري
لليبيا غير مقبول
[موسيقى]
ا
لابد صوت فيه ونقولوا يا هذا الدستور يصلح
فينا مش مكيفوني اجل عبد الحميد والله اجل
عمرو والله
هذا يصلح لليبيا ويصلح لي 100 سنه رغم ما
فيش خيار ثاني
في المقابل قال رئيس مجلس النواب الليبيه
عقيل صالح ان التعديل الدستوريه الذي اقره
مجلس النواب بيلبي تطلعات الليبيين لاجراء
الانتخابات ودع عقيله صالح خلال لقائه
قادليين في المجتمع الليبي الى توحيد
الصفوف والمشاركه في حل الازمه السياسيه
ودعم اجراء انتخابات الرئاسيه وبرلمانيه
متزامنه
قال قائد العمليات الخاصه بالقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه فيكتور خرونكو ان قوات بلاده
في باخم تعمل في ظروف شديده الصعوبه وتبذل
قصار جهدها لوقف هجمات العدو حسب قوله وقد
تفقد هورنكو وحداته المشاركه في القتال في
مدينه واشار من هناك الى اهميه التواصل
والتفاعل بين جميع الوحدات التي تشكل هيكل
القوات الخاصه لاوكرانيا
في المقابل تفقد وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
شويغو قوات الشرق في محور جنوب دونتسك
واكد شويجو على اهميه ضمان تقديم الدعم
الشامل لقوات هذه الوحده وتنظيم عمل وحدات
الدعم ولم تشهر وزاره الدفاع الى توقيت
هذه الزياره
في الاثناء قال موقع ريبار الروسي ان
القوات الروسيه تواصل تطويق مدينه وان
معارك عنيفه تدور شمالي المدينه واضاف
الموقع ان ميليشيا فاجنر سيطرت على مواقع
للجيش الاوكراني قرب بلده خروموفا على
الطريق الاخير المؤدي الى ضخمه وقال
الموقع ان القوات الروسيه تتقدم نحو
الجنوب
رفض المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
التعليق على تقارير بشان منع وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي باسرائيل من دخول الولايات
المتحده لكن المتحدث قال للجزيره ان
اواشنطن ترفض تصريحات الوزير الاسرائيلي
بشان هجمات المستوطنين في حواره وكانت
القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه قد ذكرت
نوى تدرس منع وزير الماليه وزعيم الصهيوني
الدينيه من دخول الاراضي الامريكيه على
خلفيه تصريحاته التي تمنى فيها نحو بلده
حواره في تعقيبه على حرقها من قبل عصابات
المستوطنين
اكد نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني محمد
حمدان احمد تيل التزامه بتنفيذ الاتفاق
جوبا للسلام لتحقيق الاستقرار في البلاد
ودعم التين المجتمع الدوليه لدعم اتفاق
السلام وتوفير الاحتياجات اللازمه
للنازحين
[موسيقى]
ختام هذه النشره الموجزه الى اللقاء